[Music]
we're sharing the story of a florida
principal who had a special surprise
waiting for each
student at graduation jeff reeves wanted
to personally congratulate members of
the class of 2021 for their success
after the pandemic disrupted their final
year and a half of high school
so this is what he did he hand wrote 459
notes one for each graduate our nancy
chen spoke to reeves about the heartfelt
a gesture wasn't the only special piece
of paper the matanzas high school class
of 2021 received
when they graduated on the seat of every
single graduate
was a handwritten note mike way to go
you did it i know you've worked very
hard to make it
and now you're on your way woohoo i said
don't don't stop believing
best wishes mr reeves it took eight
weeks but principal jeff reeves
says he drew on his experiences with
students and even used yearbooks and
records
to personalize 459 notes
does your hand hurt at this point no no
it was
it was a joy to do one of the recipients
was courtney wood
who starred in the school's production
of newsies this spring
so all of the notes had the students
names like individually written on the
outside of them
courtney way to go i'm so proud of you
your work on stage and behind it have
been impressive
congratulations stay positive and
focused on your goals
mr reeves that's really special this
whole year
in and of itself has felt like 10 years
and
it felt like a lot of things got
cancelled and there's been a lot of
let down so being able to be like
recognized for like individual things
that we've all done
i that meant a lot i think your class
has certainly heard more than the class
of 2020
and more than most have in quite some
time but
all of you stared at verse from the eye
and you said not today
what have they been through in this past
year and a half we've lost friends or
loved ones with covet having to learn in
a whole different style
having to teach in a whole different
style and i think it really brought us
together in a stronger sense
reeves who is named this year's
principal of the year for the district
says a good educator has compassion and
invests in students
everyone text messages everyone emails
but there is such power in a handwritten
note
i wanted to express value of what i felt
about them
and their energy and effort i just drew
on experiences i've had with the
students
whether it was their performance of the
arts their academics their
community service hours i just wanted to
try and encapsulate
memories that i've had of them noting
each and every accomplishment
one letter at a time nancy chen cbs this
morning
how much do we love mr reeves we are not
surprised that he got principal of the
year oh absolutely the fact that you
would take the time and
write some i'll bet i'll bet the kids
will save those notes for sure
so much i think that's very very nice it
gives us the opportunity to ponder what
our principals would have written in our
notes in high school enrique you want to
take a crack at that one
see i don't know i was going to say i
got i got
biggest mooch like i was always eating
everybody else's food and most athletic
most athletic so maybe
something about that i don't know what
would my principal say
mine would have been hey we tried
longwood said gail good luck good luck
i i miss being uh voted most friendliest
i lost by three votes and even i didn't
vote for me
i only know because i was on the
yearbook